andrew tate oh i'm sorry i have autism  it's it's [ __ ] andrew because of the  big boy by the way  because it was such because he was  running up here  you've never seen love on the spectrum  you don't know the different spectrums  it's my ct is flaring up  tate i saw it hold on real quick let's  clear up tate fletcher tate fletcher's  girlfriend is my trainer lacey mackey so  let's clear it up so tate fletcher was a  mixed martial artist out of jackson's a  really good dude he's also works in  movies  and an actor and  and and one of rogan's best friends and  has the best smelling beard of all time  i don't know what he shaved it off and  has a great jawline  you